objects in JavaScript an object is a
standalone entity with properties and
type a property of an object can be
explained as a variable that is attached
to the object properties can be accessed
using dot notation here I created an
object called my car and then I assigned
to properties car my car that make
equals Ford my car model equals Mustang
you can also create a property and not
assign it a value so now my car dot
color is going to be undefined now
everything is case sensitive so you have
to make sure the right things are
capitalized and you can see it's gonna
be my car that make is for my color dot
the colors undefined
properties and JavaScript objects can be
accessed or set using the bracket
notation also what I just showed you as
dot notation let me show you bracket
notation so there's a bracket notation
and also you can console that log with
bracket notation
and you can see it's Napoleon Mustang
for the model the property name can be
any string but if the name is a spacer -
or starts with a number it must be
accessed with bracket notation and it's
going to use that property the
properties do I like and then the value
is gonna log as I hit my car you can use
bracket notation with for in loops to
iterate over all the innumerable
properties of an object it's going to
paste this in so here's the function the
function is show props and when you pass
in the object and the object name one of
the reason why you passing the object
and the object name is because
JavaScript even though you're gonna pass
in the name of object here it's not
gonna know the name of the object unless
you pass it in as a string I'll show you
that later
therefore I an object that means for
each property in the object and it's
gonna set the property to I so it's
gonna say if AB dot has on property I so
if it does have that property it's going
to sit it's it's going to assign this
result which started out with it as
empty string is the object name and
that's gonna put dot and it's gonna put
the property equals and then it's going
to show what the property equals because
this is this is bracket notation we're
gonna take the object which is going to
be my car and then we're gonna look for
the property and we're just gonna polish
property like for instance it's gonna
pull the property make model color and
then even do I like and it's going to
find out what that property equals using
bracket notation well it's gonna be a
little make more sense if we actually
run this
and we're gonna pass in my car that's
the object and the object name is just
the string my car hang put that whole
thing in a console log and run okay see
it's gonna say my car that make you lord
my card out model equals Mustang my car
did that year equals 1969 my car that do
I like equals I hate my car I'm gonna go
over three ways to create an object we
have object initializer constructor
function and object that create with
object initializer I've already used
that if you do borrow my car equals new
object you're using the object
initializer another way to do that is
use the is using the following notation
so if you put these little these little
curly braces you can also define object
so the first property it color red
wheels for a toolkit engine we are
assigning engine another object so the
the value of a property can be another
object now let's look at the constructor
function another way to create an object
is with the constructor function first
you define the object type with a
constructor function and then you create
an instance of the object with new so
here's the constructor function of
Junction car
I'm guessing three three values make
model and here and now with this that
make equals make this that model equals
model this that year equals year the
word this is saying that we need to
apply the word this is talking about
this object so the car that make is
going to equal then make value that you
pushed in the car dot model is going to
equal the model value it put in and then
the car year is going to equal the year
value that we put in now we just create
an object
calling my car's follows ciliate my car
equals new car at passing Chevy Malibu
1993 another car is gonna equal new car
Mazda Miata 1990 and then if I just do
console.log now you can always add a
property to a previously defined object
for example so even though we already
created the object now we can even
console.log if we run that it's still
give nor the color at the very bottom
you can see black the final way only
talked about Krieg objects is object
that create objects can also create
using the audit that create method this
method can be very useful because it
allows you to choose the prototype
object for the object you want to create
without having to define a constructor
function while showing how to use
object.create I will also show how to
define a method for an object a method
is just a property of an object that is
a function so let me just paste this in
so first we're going to define the
prototype for our animal is going to
have type equals and vertebrates this is
just a default option for for animal so
if we put type in vertebrates the
defaults will be invertible so we can
change that we're also going to create
property that a function so when you
create a property that's a function it's
called a method and so a data type is
going to be the function console.log
this type so it can actually do
something it's not not just a value so
down here VAR m l1 equals object tree
animal so we're gonna pass in
this animal prototype integrating the
object so now it is signed and a-one
this whole thing and then we can run
animal dot display type and it's going
to display type in vertebrates however
if we create another aminal animal fish
equals off exactly animal and then do
fish that type equals fishes when we
display type it's going to be using the
fish and you can see at the end and
vertebrates fish well there's a lot more
to learn about objects but those are the
basics stay tuned for more about objects
and future videos thanks for watching my
name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good